التحضيرات للزفاف الملكي في الاردن مستمره
وثلاثه ايام بتفصلنا عن الحدث اللي مستحوذ
على اهتمام الناس اليوم في استاد عمان في
حفل ضخم ومجاني بيجمع النجوم تامر حسني
وراغب علامه واحمد سعد والفنان الاردنيتين
ديانا كرزون وزين عوض واخبروا وصول او صور
وصول الفنانين لعمان مله المنصات في حفل
ثاني كمان اعلن عنه يوم 3 يونيو وهذا
حيكون حفل جماهيري ومجاني كمان للفنان
حسين الجسمي واهداء هو من دوله الامارات
وعلى فكره التسجيل للحفله بعد الاعلان عنه
نفذ خلال 15 دقيقه غير الحفلات الفنانين
راغب على مواليد توفيق وملحم زين اعلنوا
عن طرح اغاني خاصه للاحتفال بالزفاف
وبسحرك اللي خلي الناس تصلي على النبي
الهاشمي
والزغاريد اتعلم يا قمر حزيران
لنور كل مكان
ليلي ست العواصم
اتزينت عمك
واميرك المحبوب امير نشمي مغيوب هذا ابن
هواشم هذا امير الاردن بالحب ولا اقوى
بالفرح نجوم وعم تضوى فرح الحسين ورجوه
الاردن
فرحان ومن اعز جبين سيدنا
ولمعت عيني
ملكتنا عما نعرسنا عزمتنا جينا يا
عمان ويا امير اللي ما حدا قلبك ابن
الاشرف بنيه
[موسيقى]
اشرف دنيا
وما بيعلش مين والعز
[موسيقى]